the five warned you about this one the
viral chat GPT is already ruining
education as we know it New York City's
Department of Education is Banning
controversial artificial intelligence
from school devices over concerns that
it is enabling students to cheat on
their assignments Elon Musk summing it
up it's a new world goodbye homework
teachers fear the chat about is killing
critical thinking and it helps students
generate convincing essays that fool
many anti-plagiarism software however
some have likened chat Bots to the rise
of Technology like the calculator which
was thought to be the death of math
until teachers began using it to elevate
their classwork
Greg may come to you the idea I think in
schools is about critical thinking does
and I don't mind you know a calculator
or something to help but when we when we
begin to undermine that uh how does that
affect public education at any level be
it elementary high school or college I
don't think it undermines it I think it
adds to it you think I think it adds to
it basically we think that this is a
separate part of our body but it
actually is in our hand all the time and
it makes us smarter you have everything
and we have more power in this thing
than they had in the space program this
is like when we landed on the moon this
is basically
part of your brain when you try to
describe artificial intelligence to
people they don't they don't understand
it you have to imagine your computer or
your smartphone as a paralyzed robot so
all the knowledge is in there but it's
contained there's no biological force or
chemistry
to make it autonomous or mobile so what
AI is doing it's unparalyzing the
information in your your laptop or your
phone it's it's allowing computation to
act and this is going to change medicine
it's going to change law it's going to
change everything it's basically your
laptop is going to be growing sentience
and you're going to have all the answers
in the world if you have a mole on your
on your arm you can take a picture of it
you can send it and you're going to have
the knowledge of doctors from the
beginning of time to now in that thing
that's why this is important AI is going
to change everything and it's not just
it's it's about when not if a molar in
your case a wart yes by the way if you
notice the word is gone I haven't gotten
rid of the Planters Ward but we're
working on that one together America and
no more old wives tales okay I'm not
putting any like tree serum on my foot
weirdos judge you have a sap strong
opinion about this
that and the the topic here of AI and
education and how it can undermine uh
critical thinking well there's no
question it's here and there's just a
question of when and the truth is that I
think it improves us it improves so much
of what can be done that we can't even
you know we can't even assess right now
in our Peabody Minds you know how far
this can take us my concern is this a
chat GPT you know with kids in school
we're now living in a world where the
kids don't want to be graded they don't
want to feel that this one's smarter
than them they don't want it's not about
Merit anymore it's not about grades
everybody should be treated equally this
is about going to have a negative impact
on student learning unless they develop
a way to identify when chat GPT is
writing an essay or writing poetry or a
script or whatever it is that it does
until you tell me that it can do that
I'm I'm worried for schools for learning
they've got to exercise their brains
they're not doing it they're home and
they're looking at Tick Tock and
whatever
Katie well you still can't pass the test
if you have ai write your assignment for
you I mean if you're still going into a
room without that's what they're that's
what the concern is but if you're giving
the test as a teacher without any of the
electronics maybe a regular calculator
for a math class you're still not going
to pass the test so I think teachers
just have to give their students a
choice like you can either cheat and
fail the test and fail the class or you
can do the work and get to the next
level the problem as a judge points out
is in our society now we're just passing
kids along for the sake of not hurting
their feelings getting rid of Merit
getting rid of actually accomplishing
something in education rather than you
know doing the work and taking the test
but there are ways to get around this
currently by still requiring that
students know the material outside of
just turning in a paper that was written
for someone written by someone else or
like a book report can I pretend I'm
Jesse
why wasn't this fair when I was in high
school why wasn't this there when I was
in college I had to do the work this
sucks close
but you've gotten better grades with a
thing like chat I missed the old school
way of cheating
the cat and mouse game your adrenaline's
pumping the teacher's there yes
they're doing some personal work and
they're glancing ones every once in a
while and you had it yeah either you had
a crib sheet uh that you'd write really
really small and you'd have it right
here I didn't but these are nothing's
just because he did he sat next to a
really smart kid
and you just and you lean and you tug it
and you lean and you look and then you
go like this and you do the best you can
you're just trying to survive out there
you're just trying to get a B minus or
if it's science or math yeah C plus
you'll be happy because you didn't study
and you have no idea if it works that
kind of environment is character
building
I don't endorse cheating I think it's
despicable kids out there do not cheat
but it happens and a lot of people if
they hadn't cheated wouldn't have
graduated what about the industry
money right the industry with the smart
kids make money off of the people who
don't want to study like you and you pay
them money to cheat for you right so
there's other kids that you would copy
their entire homework from and I always
wondered what was going through that
kid's mind you know they don't really
want to give you their assignment to
copy but they did it anyway yeah did
they feel like I was pressuring them yes
they did they thought that maybe you
might hurt them Jesse and sometimes if
you copy their assignments so gloriously
it's an exact replica of the assignment
and then they get in trouble too yes I
always felt like did you feel a little
bad about it what that's called it's
called feeling guilty did you ever feel
that yeah a couple times I felt guilty
but um it wasn't often that I did that
and I didn't do it it was other people
helped you tall yeah you could look over
on test day I had the best possible
there's always a girl in the class yes
and you were taller always a girl but
you can't cheat off the girls always you
gotta cheat off your smart friends but
really you don't care when you're
cheating you can care less the worst no
no the worst yeah the worst is when you
cheat off someone and they have it wrong
too oh and you're like and you're mad at
them you're mad at them beat them up in
the schoolyard like I copied your answer
and you got it all wrong I really thanks
I really hope half and Georgia did not
watch uh Uncle Jesse here give us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else